YUFEI ZHAO: For the
last few lectures,
we've been talking about the
extremal problem of forbidding
a complete bipartite graph.
So today I want to move beyond
the complete bipartite graph
and look at other
sparser bipartite graphs.
So we'll be looking at what
happens to the extremal problem
if you forbid a sparse
bipartite graph.
Recall the
Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem,
which tells you that the
extremal number for KSC
is upper bounded by something on
the order of m to the 2 minus 1
over m.
So if I give you
some bipartite H,
we know that because
it's a bipartite graph,
it is always contained in some
KST for some values of S and P.
So you already automatically
have an upper bound,
the extremal number
for this H from
the Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem.
But as you might
expect, we might
be very wasteful in this step.
And the question is,
are there situations
where we can do much better
than what is just given
by applying Kovari-Sos-Turan?
And today, I want to show
you several examples where
you can significantly
improve the bound given
by Kovari-Sos-Turan for various
sparser bipartite graphs.
The first result is the
following theorem, which
is initially due to Faraday.
And then later,
a different proof
was given by
Alon-Krivelevich-Sudov.
And the latter proof is
the one I want to present,
because it presents an
important and intricate
probabilistic technique, which
is the main reason for showing
you this theorem.
But let me tell you
the theorem first.
Here, H will be a
bipartite graph.
And it has vertex
bipartitions A and B,
such that every vertex in
A has degree at most R. The
bipartition is A and
B, and the degree in A
is at most R for every vertex
on the left side in the set A.
And I want to
understand, is there
some upper bound on the
extremal number that does better
than Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem?
And the theorem
guarantees such a bound.
So then there exists some
constant depending on H, such
that the extremal
number is upper
bounded by something to the
order of n to the 2 minus 1
over R.
Compared with Kovari-Sos-Turan
theorem, on one hand,
if your H is the complete
bipartite graph KST,
then this is the same bound
as Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem.
On the other hand, you might
have a lot more vertices in A
and a lot more vertices
in B. The hypothesis only
requires what the degrees in
A, max degrees, at most are.
So it could be a
much bigger graph.
So if you apply
Kovari-Sos-Turan,
you would get a much worse
bound compared to what
this theorem guarantees.
This 1 of R is optimal.
In this given statement, you
cannot improve this 1 of R,
because we know that from
the KST example and the lower
bounds I showed you last time,
you cannot improve upon this 1
over R. Also, in this form,
this theorem is best possible.
I want to show you a
probabilistic technique
for proving this theorem.
And this is an important idea
called dependent random choice.
So let me first give you
an informal interpretation
of what's going on.
So the idea is that if you
have a graph G with many edges,
then inside G, I can find
a large subset of vertices
U, such that all small
subsets of vertices in U
have many common neighbors.
I won't tell you what the
small and many are just yet,
but we'll see it through
the proof of the theorem,
but that's the idea.
So I give you a graph.
It's not too sparse.
It's relatively dense.
Then I should be able
to find some subset that
is fairly large so
that, let's say,
every pair of
vertices in the subset
has many common neighbors.
So let me write down--
or at least attempt to write
down-- the formal statement
of dependent random choice.
The statement of the
theorem, as I will present,
has a lot of parameters,
but don't get--
I don't want you to be
scared off by the parameters,
so I won't even tell
you what they are,
but first tell you what the
statement of the conclusion is.
And then we'll derive
what is the dependencies
on the parameters, so the
proof or the technique
is much more important
than the statement
of the theorem itself.
So I'll leave some space here.
The conclusion is that
every graph with n vertices
and at least alpha n
squared over 2 edges
contains a subset U of vertices.
U is not too small, so the
size of U is at least little u.
And such that for every subset S
of U with R elements, the set S
has at least M common neighbors.
So what's the idea here?
I give you this
graph, and I want
you to produce the set U
that has this property.
How might you go about
finding the set U?
Let me give you an analogy.
Let's suppose you have the
friendship graph on MIT campus.
And I want to
select a large set,
let's say a hundred students,
such that every pair of them
or maybe even just most pairs of
them have many common friends.
Well, how might you
go about doing that?
Well, if you select a
hundred students at random,
you're unlikely to
achieve that outcome.
They're going to be pretty
dispersed across campus.
But if you focus on
some commonalities--
so, for example,
you go to someone,
some specific
individual, and look
at their circle
of close friends,
then it seems more
likely you'll be
able to identify
a group of people
who are very well-connected
in that they, peer-wise,
have lots of common friends.
And that's the idea here.
We're going to make the
random choice by picking
that core individual--
that's the random choice--
but then make the subsequent
dependent random choice
by looking at the
group of friends
from that specific
random individual
instead of choosing the hundred
people uniformly at random,
which is not going to work.
So let's execute that
strategy on this graph.
Let me take T to be the random
set, so that's the core set.
So let T be--
for convenience, I'm going
to choose with repetition.
Instead of just
choosing one person,
I'm going to use two T vertices,
so a list of T vertices
chosen uniformly at random
from the vertex set.
So G is going to be my graph.
So the graph is G.
And what we are going to do
is look at the set A, which
is the set of common neighbors
of T, the vertices that
are adjacent to all of
T. And that's the set
I want to think about.
So I want to basically
argue that this set
A has more or less the
properties that we desire,
maybe with some small
number of blemishes, which
we will fix by cleaning up.
First, I want to guarantee
that A has a big size--
we are actually choosing
a lot of vertices.
So let's evaluate the
size of A in expectation.
By linearity of
expectation, we need
to compute the sum
of the probabilities
that individual vertices
fall in this random A.
For each particular
vertex V, when is it in A?
Well, it is in A
if T is contained
in the neighborhood of this
V. So all of your children
T fall into the neighborhood.
Otherwise, V is not going
to be contained in A.
So each individual probability
can be computed easily
by looking at the size,
so the degree of V
divided by the number of
vertices raised to the power
T--
T independent choices
chosen with replacements.
And by convexity applied
to the final expression,
we find that it is at least this
quantity here where essentially
we're taking the
averages of the degrees.
So this is by convexity.
And finally, the
graph has at least
that many edges, so the
final quantity there
is at least N alpha to
the T. Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: The question
is, in our original list,
are we allowed to have
repeated vertices?
Yes.
So it's a list, and we're
choosing every element
independently at random,
allowing repetition.
So it's sometimes called
choosing with replacement.
You choose a T.
You throw it back.
Choose another one.
The property that we're looking
for is that for every S subset,
for every r-element subset of
U, it has many common neighbors.
So let's look at such
an S. So for each S
which is an r-element
subset of the vertex set.
So r-elements subset of
V, what is the probability
that this set F
is contained in A?
I'll give you this set S.
It is contained in A if--
well, let's think
about how A is chosen.
You want this to happen.
An A is chosen as a common
neighborhood of this T--
so assets containing
A, if and only if, P
is contained in the
common neighborhood of f.
So f is fixed for now.
P is random.
So we draw the elements of
T independently, uniformly,
at random.
Therefore, this probability
is equal to the number
of common neighbors of S as a
fraction of the total number
of vertices.
This fraction
raised to the power
T. We want all S subsets of
A-- all r-element subsets
of this A-- to have at
least m common neighbors.
But maybe we cannot get that.
So let's figure out how
many bad S's are there.
How many S's do not satisfy
this condition here?
So let's call such a
set S bad if it has
fewer than m common neighbors.
And from this equation, we see
that for each fixed S that is
in r-element subset of vertices,
it is bad with probability--
it is bad if it has
few common neighbors.
Because if you have
few common neighbors,
then this probability is small.
So it is bad with probability
strictly less than m over n
raised to the power T.
We chose this A in this
dependent random way.
And basically, we
want all subsets.
All r-element subsets have
many common neighbors,
but maybe we cannot get
that at the first try.
But we only have a small
number of blemishes,
so we can fix those
blemishes by getting
rid of the possible
bad r subsets.
And that's fine to do,
as long as there are not
too many of them.
And indeed, because S is
bad with small probability,
the expected number of bad
r-element subsets of A is,
at most--
well, I look over all possible
r-element subsets of vertices.
Each one of them is bad
with this probability here.
So we have that bound.
And the point now is that if
this number is significantly
smaller than the
expected size of A, then
I can clean up all
the bad subsets
by plucking out one vertex
from each bad subset.
So indeed, that is the case,
because the expectation
of the size of A minus--
so let me call this
quantity here star--
so the size of A minus
star by what we have shown
is at least n alpha to the t
minus the quantity just now.
And I want this number
to be somewhat large.
And now let me put that as
a hypothesis of the theory.
So dependent random choice--
let u, n, r, m, t be positive
integers, alpha positive real,
and suppose n alpha to
the t minus n to the r.
Cancel the n to the
t is at least w.
That's where that
inequality comes from.
So if this is at least
w, then what we can do
is delete one vertex
from each bad subset
S. And after deleting, A
then becomes some smaller
set A prime with at least
u elements in expectation,
but then there exists
some new elements--
Let me put it this way.
We know that this is true
in expectation, thus there
exists some T, such that
that inequality is true
without the expectation, such
that there exists some T,
such that--
so this quantity
is at least that.
Now, to delete a vertex
from each bad subset,
we obtain this A prime
with at least u elements.
And we have gotten rid of all
the possible bad subsets--
so no bad r-element subsets.
And that finishes off the proof
of dependent random choice.
Just to recap, the
idea is that if you
have a dense enough
graph, then the conclusion
is that you can find a fairly
large subset of vertices,
so every pair, every r-element,
have many common neighbors.
And the way you do this, instead
of choosing your set at random,
which is not going to work, you
choose a small set of anchors.
T, you think of
that as the anchors.
You choose a bunch of anchors.
And then you look at
their common neighborhoods
and use that as
a starting point.
That will almost work.
It might not work perfectly,
but then you fix things up
by removing the blemishes.
So this is a very tricky
probabilistic idea.
It's also a very important one.
It will allow us to prove
the theorem over there
about the extremal numbers
of standard degree graphs.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is the definition
of bad set for any subset of V
or is it only for subsets of A?
YUFEI ZHAO: The question is,
in the definition of bad,
do I use this definition
for all subsets
of V, all r-element subsets,
or just subsets of A?
So I use it to mean all subsets
of V, because A is random.
A is random, so the
definition of bad
does not depend
on the randomness.
It only depends on
the original graph.
AUDIENCE: How is the badness
dependent on any probability?
YUFEI ZHAO: The badness
does not-- so the
question us, how does
the badness depend
on any probability?
The badness does not
depend on the probability,
but A is random.
So the number of bad
r-element subsets of A
is a random variable.
So each individual-- so
you start with a graph.
Some r-element
subsets of graphs.
Some are not.
And now I choose this random
A in this dependent random
manner.
And A might contain
some bad subsets.
I'm trying to calculate how
many bad subsets does A have.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],, because
an S is neither bad or not bad.
You said it's bad
with probability.
YUFEI ZHAO: So your
concern is each S
is bad with probability--
ah.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: Fine.
Yeah.
Thank you.
So each bad subset--
OK, so for each
fixed bad subset,
it is contained in
A with probability.
Thank you.
I hope this makes it clear.
So the probability of the--
the property of being
bad is not random,
but it containing A is random.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: So the question
is, why is this true?
So why are these
two events the same?
And it's kind of hard to
steer the definition a bit.
So T is chosen as the
common neighborhoods--
sorry.
You choose T at random.
And you choose A to be the
common neighborhood of T.
And so how do you
characterize subsets of A
if every element is
connected to all of T?
You have to think about it.
Any more questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: We pick T at random.
T is uniform.
So the question is,
how are we picking T?
T is uniform at random.
Oh, great.
So the question is, how
do we pick the little t
in the theorem statement?
It depends on the application.
And that's a little bit weird,
because in the statement
of the theorem, the little t
shows up in the inequality,
but not in the conclusion.
So you think of t as
an auxiliary parameter.
So the little t comes
up in the proof,
but not really in
the conclusion.
Any more questions?
It's a tricky lemma.
It's a tricky idea.
So now let me use it to prove
the statement over there.
And here, it's not so hard.
So it's mostly an application
of this dependent random choice
lemma.
So for all H that's
in the theorem--
so let me prove this
lemma-- so for all H
that's in the theorem,
there exists a constant C,
such that every graph with at
least C n to the 2 minus 1 over
r edges contains
a vertex U with--
so vertex subset U with
the size of U equal to B--
so B comes from the
vertex by partition of H.
It's a constant--
such that every r-element
subset in B has--
so r-element subset in U has
lots of common neighbors.
That's at least
another constant,
which is the number
of vertices in H--
that many common neighbors.
So you see, it's
a direct corollary
of the dependent random
choice lemma by setting it
in the right
parameters and, indeed,
by the dependent random choice
lemma where we choose this T--
this auxiliary variable T
in independent random choice
lemma--
equal to r.
So suffices to check that
there exists of C such that--
plug it into that expression,
that inequality, up there.
So n2Cn to the minus 1 over r--
raised to the power
r minus n choose r.
And then this expression here.
So I'm just plugging in the
various graph parameters
into the dependent
random choice statement.
And I want to show that you
can find a constant C such
that this inequality is true.
And indeed, these
exponents, they cancel out,
so the first term is
simply 2C raised to the r.
And the second one,
because, again,
you notice that the
exponents work out just fine,
so it is, at most, a constant.
So you can choose C big
enough so that this is true.
So it's a direct verification
of the hypothesis of the lemma.
And now we're ready to prove
the theorem over there.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: How do you have size
A plus B common neighbors?
Isn't that the entire graph?
Or can I just [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: The
question is, how do you
have size A plus B
commons neighbors?
So H is fixed.
And A and B are
constants, so A plus B
is the number of vertices
of H. That's a constant.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
Oh, OK.
YUFEI ZHAO: Yeah, I'm talking
about common neighbors,
not in H, but in the big
graph G as n vertices.
Now, I like questions.
It's tricky.
This is a tricky argument,
so please do ask questions
if you're confused.
And there are times
when I may not
have explained it very well,
so please do ask questions.
So let's prove the theorem.
And now we're almost there.
The idea is that we
embed the vertices of B
into the big graph G one by one.
Sorry.
First, embed B into the vertices
of G using U from the lemma--
so the lemma that
we just stated.
And they claim that once
you have done that--
so the vertices of B--
and now I need to embed the
remaining vertices of A.
And I can do this one
by one, because if I
need to embed some vertex of A,
has, at most, r neighbors to B.
But I have embedded
B in such a way
that they have a lot of
common neighbors inside G.
So I can always do it.
So I can always embed
the vertices of A one
at a time in such a way that
I even avoid collisions.
I don't allow vertices to be
embedded into the same place.
This is all using that B,
embedding a B, which is U,
has many common neighbors in
G. So once you put that in.
And the rest, you just
make one choice at a time.
And you need to embed
a second vertex,
or you can find somewhere in
their common neighborhood that
allows you to do it.
So you embed the
vertices one at a time,
and then you finish
embedding the whole graph.
Any questions?
It's a tricky argument.
So let's take a break, and I
want you to think about it.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: So the question
is, how do you embed A
without having any collisions?
So I put in the vertices of
B so that every r of them
have many neighbors.
And now, I want to try to
embed the vertices of A one
by one in any order.
Think about-- you
pick the first vertex.
Where can it go?
It has-- let's say it's
adjacent to the first three
vertices of B. So,
in the embedding,
it has to go in the common
neighborhood of those three
vertices, which
we know is large.
So I put them anywhere.
And I do the same for
the second vertex,
do the same for
the fourth vertex.
So I just keep on going.
Because the common
neighborhood is large,
it may be that some of
the potential vertices I
might embed is already
used by the previous steps
in the process.
But because I always
have at least A
plus B common
neighbors, I always
have some possibilities
that remain.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE],,
like the last line
of the proof to
[INAUDIBLE] delete
a vertex from each
bad subset, and then
to make that [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: Ah.
The question is, how does
this bad subset deletion work?
So you have this A
which is fairly large.
And you know that there
exists some instance-- there's
some incidence of
this randomness that
produces for you a situation
where A has very few bad r
subsets.
So then I take A and I
delete from A one vertex
in each bad subset.
I haven't changed the
size of A very much.
A is still quite large
after this deletion,
but now A has no bad
subsets remaining,
because I've gotten rid of
one vertex from each one,
from each bad subset.
So they're very
similar to what we've
seen before, the random process
for creating an H-free graph.
You generate a
random H-free graph
which has very few copies
of H relative to the number
of edges, and then
you get rid of them
by removing one edge
from each copy of H.
So with the theorem that
we saw in the first part
of the lecture, we
saw how to improve
on the bound of Kovari-Sos-Turan
in some circumstances, namely
one where the graph that
you're forbidding, this H,
essentially has bounded degree.
We stated something
a bit stronger,
namely has bounded
degree from one side.
And that's a pretty
general result.
And now I want to look at
some more specific situations
where you might be able
to improve further.
So what are some nice
bipartite graphs?
One that comes up is
kind of even cycles.
So if you have
C4, C6, and so on.
And you see C4 is
the same as K2,2,
which we already saw before.
But even C6, the
techniques so far
allow us to obtain, with the
theorem that we just saw--
gives us a bound on C6 that's
more or less the same as that
of C4, namely n to the 3/2.
So what's the truth for C6?
Well, it turns out that
you can do much better.
So this is the theorem
of Bondy and Simonovits
that, for all
integers k at least 2,
there exists some constant C
such that the extremal number--
well, I'm going to
use C too many times.
So I'll just say that the
extremal number of C2 sub k
is, at most, on the order
of n to the 1 plus 1 over k.
So, in particular, for 6
cycles, the upper bound
is 4/3 in the exponent.
It's better than the 3/2.
So there's another class
of graphs where there
are some nice upper bounds.
So you can ask, well, just
like Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem
for complete bipartite
graphs, do we
know matching lower
bound constructions?
And what is known is
that it is tight only
for a small number of cases.
And the others, we do not
know whether they are tight.
So this Bondy-Simonovits
theorem, it is tight for k
being 2, 3, or 5,
and open for others.
So there are constructions
for C4,3, C6,3 and C10,3,
but not for C8,3.
That's an open problem.
The proof of the
Bondy-Simonovits theorem
is slightly involved,
but I want to show you
a weaker result that
already contains
a lot of interesting ideas.
So a weaker result is this.
That for every
integer k at least 2,
there exists a constant C such
that every n-vertex graph G
with at least C--
so this-- the correct--
the same order of
number of edges--
so we know for
Bondy-Simonovits, it
contains an even cycle
of length exactly 2k.
So we'll show something
slightly weaker
that contains an even cycle
of length, at most, 2k.
Which, in other words, says that
the extremal number, if you--
so we haven't introduced
this notation,
but, hopefully, you can
guess what it means.
Then, if you forbid
all of these cycles,
then it is this quantity there.
So I'll show this weaker
result. All right.
Let's' do it.
First, I want to show you a
couple of easy preparatory
lemmas.
The first-- so every graph G
contains a subgraph with min
degree at least the half of--
at least half of the
average degree of G.
So you have a graph G. It
has large average degree.
It has lots of edges.
But maybe there are some
small degree vertices.
And it will be useful to know
that the minimum degree is
actually quite large as well.
So it turns out, by
passing to a subgraph,
you can guarantee that.
How do you think we
might prove this?
I give you a graph.
I know it has lots of edges.
But maybe some vertices
have small degree.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: So you suggest
dependent random choice.
That's a heavy hammer for
such a simple statement.
And so it turns out we can
do something even simpler.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: So we'll just throw
out the min degree vertices.
So throw out the
small degree vertices.
So if the average degree is
2t then the number of edges
is number of vertices times t.
And you see that removing
a vertex of degree t,
or at most t, cannot
decrease average degree.
So I have this
process where I remove
vertices that are less than
half of average degree.
And the average degree
never goes down,
so I keep on doing this.
Average degree stays the same.
Well, it can go up,
but it never goes down.
And when I stop, I don't have
any more small degree vertices
to get rid of.
Why does the process
even terminate?
Maybe we end up with the empty
graph, which is not so useful.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The average
degree is [INAUDIBLE]..
YUFEI ZHAO: He said the average
degree is non-decreasing.
But how do I know the graph
has at least some number
of vertices when I stop?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: So if you--
you must terminate.
You must terminate
because every graph,
if you have way too small
number of vertices--
because, for example, if--
we'll just notice that
every graph with, at most,
2t vertices has average
degree less than 2t.
So you'll never get
below 2t vertices.
You'll run out of room
if you go too far.
Because that's the
first preparation lemma.
The second one is
that every graph G
has a bipartite subgraph
with at least half
of the number of edges
as the original graph.
This is a very nice
and quick exercise
in the probabilistic method.
So we can color every
vertex black and white
uniformly at random.
And the expected number
of black to white edges
is exactly half of the
original number of edges
by linearity of expectations.
So there's some instance with
at least that many black-white
edges, and that's a
bipartite subgraph.
So now we can prove the theorem
about even cycles, the weaker
theorem at least.
I start with a graph
which has a lot of edges.
But by these two lemmas, and
changing constant somewhat,
I can obtain a subgraph with--
that's bipartite and has
min degree quite large.
So I lose, at most,
a constant factor,
and I get basically
within a factor of 2 of--
well, factor of 4 of
the average degree.
So let me call this
quantity delta,
the min degree in this subgraph,
this bipartite subgraph.
Let's think about what
happens to this graph
if I start with an
arbitrary vertex.
So now I have a min
degree condition.
It's, really, all vertices are
now kind of the same to me.
So pick an arbitrary vertex,
and look at its neighborhood.
It has at least delta
edges coming out.
So let me call the first vertex
level 0, and the second set
level 1.
It's bipartite, so there
are no edges within level 1.
Let's expand out even further.
Can there be some collisions
where two of these edges
go to the same vertex?
Well, if there were,
then I find a C4.
So if I assume--
so let's assume that
there's no C4, C6,
and so on, C2k,
for contradiction.
So because there's no
C4, all the endpoints
of this path of length 2
are distinct in level 2.
And you keep going, or you
keep expanding further.
And so on.
And all the way to level t.
And all of these guys
must be distinct as well.
Because, otherwise, you'll find
a cycle of length, at most, 2t.
So when you do this
expansion, each step,
you get distinct vertices.
And you also have no
edges inside each part
because you are looking
in the bipartite setting.
So how many vertices
do you get at the end?
Well, I have a min
degree condition.
The min degree
condition tells me
that I expand by a factor of at
least delta minus 1 each time.
So the number of
vertices in here
is at least delta minus
1 raised to the power t--
so raised to the power k.
Here's k.
And expand all the
way to the end.
But, you see, that number
there is quite large.
So, in particular,
if t is large enough,
then it's bigger than n.
And that will be
a contradiction,
because you only had n vertices
in the graph to begin with.
Therefore, the
assumption that there
are no cycles, even cycles
of length, at most, 2k,
is incorrect.
And that finishes the proof.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are the ideas for the
full Bondy-Simonovits theorem
similar?
YUFEI ZHAO: So the question has
to do with, in the original,
in the full Bondy-Simonovits
theorem, what do we need to do?
Are they similar?
So, certainly, you want
to do something like this.
But, then, you also
want to think about,
if you do have short cycles,
how can you bypass them?
So there's a more
careful analysis
of what happens
with shorter cycles.
And we will not get into that.
Any more questions?
All right.
So the first thing that
we did in today's lecture
has to deal with what--
AUDIENCE: Quick question.
YUFEI ZHAO: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So why is--
so why are all vertices
distinct for level k?
Or are they just
defined that way?
YUFEI ZHAO: So question
is, why are the vertices
distinct for level k?
So at level k, if you
have some collapse,
then it came from two different
paths, therefore forming a C2k.
AUDIENCE: OK.
YUFEI ZHAO: So now I want to
revisit the first theorem that
happened in today's
lecture, namely
if you have this H,
bipartite A and B.
So we saw the hypothesis was
that if every vertex in A
had bounded degree,
degree, at most, r, then
we got the upper bound
on the extremal number.
That was n to the
2 minus 1 over r.
And, in particular,
for r equals to 2,
suppose I have that
situation there.
Suppose that the degree
for every vertex in A
is, at most, 2.
Then the first theorem
guaranteed us that the extremal
number is on the order,
at most, n the 3/2,
just like the extremal number
for 4 cycles, for K2,2's.
And, of course, this
statement is tight,
in the sense that if I change
this 3/2 to any smaller number,
then, well, just taking
H to be K2,2 violates it.
So I cannot replace in this
generality 3/2 by any smaller
number, because we know that
the extremal number for K2,2 is
this order.
But is that the
only obstruction?
So if H is not K2,2, well, you
can make some sillier examples
too by taking K2,2 and
add some more edges.
So lets forbid H from
having a K2,2 subgraph.
Can you do better now?
So in this case, can you
improve for the specific H
that exponent?
And we already saw one case
where you can do this, namely
in Bondy-Simonovits
theorem for cycles.
Or if you only applied this
theorem here, you get 3/2,
but Bondy-Simonovits tells
you a much better exponent.
So let's explore the situation.
And it turns out, in a very
recent theorem that is only
proved the last couple of years
by David Conlon and Joonkyung
Lee, they showed
that for every H
as above, there exists
constants little c
and big C such that the
extremal number of H
is upper bounded by something
where I can decrease 3/2
to some even smaller number.
So, somehow, this 3/2, now
we understand is really
because of the presence of K2,2.
The graph has--
if H has no K2,2,
then some smaller
number suffices.
And I want to use
the rest of today
to explain how to prove
that theorem there.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: The C is not
independent of H [INAUDIBLE]..
YUFEI ZHAO: That's right.
So the question is,
is C independent of H?
So C depends on H. So C, they
are dependent on H. Questions?
Let me put this question in a
slightly different formulation
that is also equivalent.
So in graph theory, there is
a notion of a subdivision.
And, in particular, a one
subdivision of graph H
is this operation where
you start with a graph--
let's say this graph here--
and you add a
vertex to the middle
of every edge of this graph.
So, initially, it's 4 vertices.
Now you add a new
vertex to every edge.
So you subdivide every edge
into a path of two edges.
That's called a subdivision.
So for today's lecture, let me
denote subdivisions by a prime.
And, in particular,
if this is K4,
then I will denote this
graph here K4 prime.
So, for example, K3 prime,
that's a triangle subdivided--
well, that's a C6, [INAUDIBLE].
So observe that every H that
comes up in this theorem
here is a subgraph of
some subdivision, some one
subdivision of a clique.
Because the vertices on
the left in A are degree 2,
you think of them as
midpoints of edges.
But because you are
K2,2 free, you--
if you collapse those path
of lengths 2 to single edges,
you do not end up
with parallel edges.
So it is the subgraph of this
one subdivision of some graph,
which, then, you can
complete to a clique.
So this theorem
here is equivalent,
at least qualitatively, to the
statement that for every t,
there exists some
constants, again
depending on t, such that the
extremal number of the one
subdivision of a clique is
bounded by something where
we can improve upon the exponent
in the first theorem in today's
lecture.
So that theorem there.
So these two theorems
are equivalent because
of this remark.
Any questions so far
about the statements?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In the remark,
how do you deal with, like,
[INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: Question,
in the remark,
how do you deal with vertices
with degree less than 2?
Complete it to a vertex degree
of-- vertex of degree 2.
Add another edge.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: Add another
edge to a new vertex.
AUDIENCE: OK, sure.
YUFEI ZHAO: Any more questions?
All right.
So the proof I want to show
you is due to Oliver Janzer,
and for this clique
subdivision theorem.
And this proof
produces that C sub t
equals to 1 over 4t minus 6.
So if you plug in
t equals to 3, you
find that the exponent here is
actually right for the 6 cycle.
So it actually agrees
with what we know.
So I want to show you some of
the main ideas from this proof.
Just like the proof of--
that we saw for the cycles,
even cycles theorem,
it will be helpful to start
with some preparation.
You start with a graph
that, even though it
has a lot of edges,
may have lots
of vertices with
high degree, lots
of vertices with low degree.
It's nice to clean
it up somewhat.
And so let me state a
preparatory lemma, which
we will not prove, but
it's of a similar nature
to this very easy lemma
that we saw earlier but
with a bit more work.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: Yes.
Originally, I put a C over
here, but now it's OK.
So there exists a Ct.
So the preparation
is that we're going
to pass through a large,
almost regular subgraph.
The lemma-- so don't worry
too much about the details,
and I'll tell you
what the idea is.
So for every alpha, there exists
constants beta and K such that
for every C and n
sufficiently large,
every n-vertex graph
G with lots of edges--
so C n to the 1
plus alpha edges--
has a subgraph G
prime such that--
so I want some properties.
First, G prime has
lots of vertices.
So n to the beta, so it's
still lots of vertices.
You do some polynomial in n.
And, 2, it has
still lots of edges
relative to the number
of vertices it has.
So, basically,
changing the constants,
if I start with n
to the 1 plus alpha,
I still have, roughly, number
of vertices to the 1 plus
alpha, number of edges.
It is almost regular, in the
sense that the max degree of G
does not differ from
its minimum degree
by more than a constant factor.
So you do have vertices
that are too small degree.
You don't have vertices
that are too large degree.
And, finally, G
prime is bipartite,
and the two parts
of this bipartition
have sizes differing by
a factor, at most, 2.
So if you like, think of G
as a regular bipartite graph.
But this is the
preparation lemma.
We'll just make our
life a bit easier.
So, from now on, let's
treat G as a constant
in our asymptotic notation
to simplify the notation.
So you have this graph G.
It's a bipartite graph.
And for a pair of
vertices on one side A--
so there are no edges in A.
But for a pair of vertices,
I say that this u, v is light.
So it's not an edge, but
I talk about these pairs.
I say that it is light if the
number of common neighbors
between--
of u and v is at least 1
and less than t choose 2.
So it has some common
neighbors, but not too many.
And then we say that
this pair is heavy
if the number of
common neighbors
is at least t choose 2.
So if a pair u, v has
some common neighbors,
then it's either light or heavy.
I claim that if
G is a Kt prime--
so this is the one
subdivision of Kt--
free bipartite graph with
vertex bipartition A union B--
so U. Not A, but U union
B. U will eventually
be a subset of A. Such that all
the vertices on the left of U
have to be at least delta,
and U is not too small.
So it's at least 4Bt over delta.
Don't worry about it for now.
So think of delta--
this is a min degree.
So it is somewhat smaller
than the average--
I mean, it's basically the
average degree of your graph.
And B, think of as n.
It's more or less the
whole set of vertices.
Then the conclusion
is that there
exists a u in a lot of
light pairs in the set
U. There exists a vertex
in many light pairs.
It's important that we
assume that this graph G
if Kt prime free.
Because, otherwise, you could
imagine a situation where,
essentially, you have a
complete bipartite graph
and every pair of
vertices is heavy.
So you don't have any
light pairs at all.
So having Kt prime free somehow
allows us to find light pairs.
So let's see the
proof of this lemma.
So you combine some nice
ideas that we've seen earlier
in the course, namely
double counting,
and also uses Turan's theorem.
So, first, let's do a double
counting argument similar
to the proof of the
Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem,
where let's count the
number of K1,2's like that.
So the number of K1,2's
like that between U and B.
I claim one way to count
this is to look through all
the vertices on the right side,
look at how many neighbors it
has, and sum up the
degrees choose 2.
So skipping some--
I mean, I can tell
you what comes out.
So, by convexity,
we find that it
is at least this quantity here.
And then, assuming the
minimum degree condition,
we find that this
quantity is quite large.
So this is a calculation
very similar to what
we did for the proof of
Kovari-Sos-Turan theorem.
The low degree vertices in B do
not contribute much to the sum.
So this sum is large, and it
sums over all vertices in B,
but the low degree vertices in
B, they contribute very little.
Because if we sum over
all the vertices of B
with degree less than 2t,
then, for each summand,
it's, at most, 2
t squared, which,
again, by the assumption
of delta, is less than half
of the total sum.
So the low degree vertices of
B do not contribute very much
to the sum.
So let's look at the
higher degree vertices.
For the higher
degree vertices, they
contribute a substantial chunk.
And the most
important thing here
is that, among these vertices,
there are no t mutually heavy--
so not among these vertices,
but in U. If you look at U,
there are no t mutually
heavy vertices in U.
If you have t mutually
heavy vertices in U, then
what happens?
So if you have t
mutually heavy vertices.
If you had, let's say,
three vertices in U,
they're mutually heavy, each one
of them, because they're heavy,
I can find many
common neighbors.
So I can build this
path of length 2.
I can build another
And I don't run out of vertices
because they're all heavy.
They all have at least t
choose 2 common neighbors.
So I can build the
subdivision of Kt.
So there are no
mutually heavy vertices
in U. So where have
we seen this before?
So you have-- think about
the neighborhood of a vertex
in B. Because it's
inside a neighborhood,
all the pairs are
either heavy or light,
and there are no t
mutually heavy vertices.
So, then, Turan's
theorem tells us
that there must be
many light vertices.
That there are many light
vertices in this neighborhood.
So the number of light pairs
in the neighborhood of this v,
if it has at least t neighbors--
or else you run out of room--
is at least-- so if you think
about what Turan's theorem
says, that the number of known
edges is at least this quantity
here, which is at least
the degree of v squared--
degree of v.
So Turan's theorem tells us that
there cannot be so many heavy
pairs inside a neighborhood
of a vertex in B,
so there must be
many light pairs.
And now we sum over
all vertices in B.
We obtain that U has
a lot of light pairs.
We might have overcounted
and a little bit,
because each light pair
is overcounted only
by a bounded number of
times because it's light.
So it's overcounted by
less than K choose 2 times.
So that's just a constant
factor, and we're OK with that.
So that's the
conclusion for now.
This lemma tells us that you
have lots of light pairs in U.
And what we're going to do is
to keep on shrinking this U.
So U is going to be a
subset of A. Initially,
let's let U be the
entire set A. It tells us
that there's one vertex in A
with lots of light neighbors.
Take that vertex,
choose its neighborhood.
Apply the lemma again.
Find another vertex with lots
of internal light neighbors.
Keep on going.
And then we build a
large light clique.
So that's the idea.
So we'll find that--
so we'll see that if
this delta is bigger
than, basically, the quantity
claimed in the theorem--
so t minus 2 over 2t minus 3--
and sufficiently
large C, then there
exists the sequence U1, U2,
U3, so on, all the way to Ut,
and the sequence
of vertices v1, v2,
vt, such that, initially,
I take A. And the idea is,
initially, I take
v1 to be whatever
comes out of that lemma.
And I want the property that
all of the vi, vj's are light.
And 2 is that no three of these
v's have a common neighbor.
And, I think, once you have
these two properties, then
you can find your
clique subdivision.
You find these t light vertices.
So if you have v1, v2, v3, v4,
you have these light vertices,
and I can build a
clique subdivision
from these light vertices.
Because they're light, they have
at least one common neighbor
for each pair.
I just keep building them.
So I build these
common neighbors.
Well, you should
be somewhat worried
that I end up using
the same vertex twice.
But, of course, that
should not be a worry
if I guarantee that no three
of them have a common neighbor.
They cannot collapse.
And you cannot have two
vertices end up being the same.
Otherwise, I would
violate property b.
So these two
properties alone allow
you to build a Kt subdivision.
But how do we find
this sequence?
Well, so we build it
iteratively using that lemma.
You start with one vertex
guaranteed by that lemma.
You look at its neighborhood.
You pick another vertex
guaranteed by the lemma.
You look at its neighborhood.
And so on.
And you build this
sequence of light clique.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: Ah.
The light neighborhood, yes.
So we're not in
the graph any more.
So everything's inside
A. Everything's inside A.
So let me finish off
the list of properties,
and we're almost there.
Third property I want is that,
when I do this operation,
I do not reduce my space of
possibilities by too much.
Namely, that the size of U does
not go down too substantially.
And that's guaranteed
by the lemma.
And, 4 is that--
basically this
picture over here--
vi is light to
all of U i plus 1.
So I claim that you can
find the sequence satisfying
these properties.
And the reason is that you are
repeatedly applying the lemma.
So repeatedly apply the lemma.
The lemma doesn't
address this part
about triple vertices
having common neighbors.
But I claim that's actually
not so hard to deal with.
Because if you think
about how many vertices,
how many possibilities,
this restriction eliminates,
b only eliminates at
each step t choose 2,
because this is coming from
the light restriction, times,
at most--
so another t choose 2.
And this comes-- the first
one comes from pairs of v1
through vt.
So eliminates, at
most, this many--
times the max degree.